as the chairman of the sovereignty
Council Abdel fatah al-burhan represents
his country on the world stage
he took the opportunity to portray
himself and his army as the ones on the
right side of History painting the
paramilitary group they're fighting as
the ones in the wrong
we call upon the interim president and
we call upon the International Community
to designate these groups and their
allies as terrorist groups that must be
countered by all they must be fought to
protect the Sudanese people the region
and the entire world and they're
responsible for killing thousands and
the displacement of Millions
his rival for power the head of the
rapid support forces Muhammad hamdan
daglow or meridi tried to send his own
message on video just an hour before
burhan's speech
the rapid support forces are fully ready
for a total ceasefire across Sudan
here at the United Nations officials say
there's a sense that neither side is
ready to end this deadly conflict that
is entering its sixth month and I think
that's the only thing that is going to
bring these two to the table when
there's enough pressure on them that
impacts them personally their groups
personally that's when you'll start to
see progress so I think you'll see over
the coming weeks and months an increase
in the pressure from the UN and the
broader International Community to try
to bring this senseless violence to an
end
funded and agencies say they don't have
nearly enough either more than a
thousand children have died of
starvation and measles more than 5
million people have fled the fighting
neighboring countries happen to be some
of the poorest countries in the world
Chad the Central African Republic South
Sudan some of which we're already
experiencing their own conflicts luckily
these countries have welcomed in
Sudanese refugees but they have very
little resource in New York fighting the
battle for public opinion in Sudan
fighting on the streets with experts
warning they see very little signs of
optimism that the guns will fall silent
anytime soon paddickle Hayne Al Jazeera
at the United Nations
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera